a gruesome hitandrun murder sparking
outrage in America sickening video
posted to social media showing a pair of
teen Killers laughing as they
intentionally plow their car into
64-year-old retired police chief Andreas
Propst who was out for a morning bike
ride last month in Vegas if you warning
this is extremely tough to
watch oh the victim of the teams cruy
left on the side of the road later
discovered by his daughter who got an
apple alert that her father had fallen
he was then rushed to the hospital and
pronounced dead cops already arresting
the 17-year-old driver on murder charges
and prosecutors are planning to charge
him as an adult but they need the
Public's help in hunting down the person
in the passenger side who recorded the
horrific clip ropes is remembered by his
family as an amazing man and array of
sunshine Greg I mean we have seen this
video I mean we couldn't play the whole
thing when you saw it for the first time
it had to have had a impact it's it's
like um I I talked I actually tweeted
about it being like the Isis video it's
hard to affect like the city mentality
and in anybody's World these days it's
like talking to a drug addict hey did
you know crime is really bad for you and
it's like dude no man maybe you should
cut back on the crime and say dude we're
good we're good so what you need
transformational experience and events
that would change this mindset the
before and after incident it like the
Isis videos the thing that jars you into
a new reality some of the when you see
this you cannot unsee it it's just it's
why I avoided the Isis videos you can't
like I knew that would change me
permanently but that video of that
heinous murder is such a
transformational event I saw it it's now
in my brain it's changed the way I think
I imagine
it this happened to a lot of people it's
something you didn't want to see the
problem is we're the only people that
care the media doesn't care if the
pigment doesn't fit their program the
villains villains must be white or it
didn't happen the fact is uh they
recycled and recycled and recycled the
George Floyd video so much that it
transformed a country into a
self-loathing self-destructive entity
the C City's leaders stood by and let
the violent mobs beat and kill people
because they were brainwashed by that
video into believing that we deserved it
something like this what just happened
here is rare that's why it's so shocking
and you don't you don't have to Riot
over this now imagine if those sentences
were said after George Floyd instead of
this reflects an entire corrupt racist
system an entire vocation of racist
officers we don't do that here because
we love our country we find this heinous
and disgusting but we're not saying it's
a it's emblematic of a group unlike the
left and unlike the mainstream
media judge so what do you think the
chances are authorities break this teen
and just get him to admit who was
sitting shotgun filming Oh They'll break
him um my understanding is that this
teen has some priors which of course uh
lends to his being required to be
treated and tried in an adult court but
make no mistake even though he's 17 and
tried in adult in an adult Court his the
sentencing can be 35% less because he is
17 years old so will they get the other
guy will they break him there's no
question uh but but this is a a filming
of a public
execution okay with no regard for the
consequences and this is not just
repulsive and something that is not
forgettable you know when Greg talks
about the Isis videos and you know there
are certain things you don't forget but
this isn't about the Devolution of our
society I mean this is more than just
one case this is a we're in a place
where murder is a sport where the video
is your
bravado where the victim the innocent
silent victim of crime is nothing more
than collateral damage and where no
justice will ever be gotten for the
victim or the victim's family and that's
all we're seeing now with this
generation Z that doesn't care about
consequences which to them now is a
relative ly New Concept and I'm going to
spin off of what what Greg just talked
about the villains for the media to
cover must be white or it didn't happen
so let's talk about the impact of George
Floyd this murderer was 17 years old
Alle leged murderer the kid who hit him
with the bike and said yeah let's get
his ass okay there's no question that
this was an intentional murder now at
the time of George Floyd he was 13 or 14
at the time of um who was it Michael
Brown uh yeah hands up don't shoot which
we knew was not accurate because Michael
Brown reached for the cops gun first
this kid was eight years old all right
and so we watched businesses burn
neighborhoods burn murder Mayhem no
consequences America was Under Fire and
this is what we got and this is what
we're going to have for the next 20
years unless that pendulum swings the
other way and you know the juvie Court
you know and lowering the age is a bunch
of nonsense until we as a society have
the nerve and The Verve and the
determination to lock these kids up to
make them examples they're going to
continue to do this Harold Ford Jr so I
share your view uh judge that this young
man or these young men should be tried
as adults um this is just utter evil uh
there's
no way to characterize it any any more
than that um we can talk about the Floyd
thing and the race thing later but I I
don't this is just I don't care what
color they are uh I don't care what part
of the country they're from uh I hope
they break this kid and he he tells on
the other kit and that they not only are
tried as adults but I hope they don't
get the 35% reduction from the judge now
they're innocent till proven guilty but
it looks as if they're guilty here and
if indeed they're proven guilty with
what happened here um I think there
should be aggravating before we went on
Dana was asking a question about could
there be an aggravated sentence or could
we increase the penalty here I think we
ought to look at a federal law in this
country uh that when you kill police
officers uh retired or not uh that there
should be a different standard uh and
this is one of those cases that I hope
whether the media has covered it
appropriately uh enough or excessively
it doesn't look like this is the first
I'd heard of the of this matter um this
is something that we as a nation should
consider I hope in Nevada or Nevada
however you say it uh that they they
contemplate doing something like that
Dana it's Nevada for when you're run for
president just make sure you say it
correctly okay so I don't have a ton to
add to what everyone has said I think
there's a scary lack of humanity that is
out there and I also think that do you
remember when the kids were doing the
knockout game yeah it's almost as if
they don't think that that's a real
person right car was also stolen but to
the media point so we are doing the
story it's leading the five let me tell
you that's a big deal when something
leads the five is as big and you can you
can find this on story on Twitter but
when Jordan Ney MH put the
crazed drug addict who was threatening
to kill people on a subway when Jordan
Neely white guy M former Marine put him
in a headlock and choke hold released
him after that he died that was
everywhere there were protests oh and
guess what we heard we heard from AOC
then you heard from the squad at that
point you don't hear anything about this
and there the depravity depravity I
can't how do you say that word I've been
thinking about it all day um it is a
scary thing to witness the only thing
that is maybe good in terms of fighting
crime is that these criminals want to
film themselves so that helps
prosecutors prove in a court of law
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and hopefully
he goes to jail quickly and for the rest
of his life that makes me think how many
of these murders we don't see the Glee
in the murders because they didn't film
it we just happen to be we just happen
to see this is there a possibility that
you could execute somebody 65% of them
if it's a 35%
reduction well and I wonder do they have
the death penalty in Nevada not for
someone that's 17 abely not but you know
what Dana to your point there's no
question the technology and the
advancements that have been made and
cameras everywhere they helped law
enforcement uh in a way that was never
possible all right well this was Pure
Evil and these people should be punished
severely hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now